[Applause]
awesome that was that was on point for
doing all the housekeeping so data
Version Control this is a very
simplified uh view of the machine
learning process so usually when you do
machine learning you build some kind of
model and how do you go about that you
have two ingredients towards that model
uh one is the code so you specify the
algorithm the architecture your training
Loop uh within your code and the other
thing that you have is the data so you
collect uh some kind some data that is
relevant to your problem um in the
beginning you don't know how relevant it
may be or may not be and then as the
project goes on there is a lot of things
that change so you might have do
experiments figure out that certain
architectures perform better than others
you just try out different kinds of
architectures you might find a buck in
your code that you want to fix uh new
features are required by changing uh
requirements of the from management or
of the project um and you're also going
and you might collect new data people
are using your uh deployed model uh you
might want to use that to retrain your
model periodically or you find out that
some uh data or some parts of the data
that you had are faulty wrong um or just
not relevant because you had
distribution drift or don't don't need
that so we see that there's a lot of
Dynamics happening within the code as
well as the data which yields different
versions of the model uh different uh
performances of the model and we do
treat code as a first class citizen
already so we because these data and
code are the fundamental assets that
produce the output uh the model that we
have we do version our code um using git
uh to yeah enable reproducibility and uh
work with our colleagues but we don't
really do it for data yet at least uh
some of us don't
and um when you work on a project you
might find yourself starting and ending
up with something like this so we see
that doing or versioning your data or
having the need to version your data is
something something that just naturally
comes up within a within project and if
you want to move fast you do a solo
experimentation this might even be
enough and fine because you do know what
is V3 experiment to uh you have some
kind of mental Association to that but
you can also easily see that when you
have bigger teams when you want to work
on a project that that is bigger uh than
yourself so people can get on and
offboard it to the project um that this
really doesn't scale because what the
hell is between V3 experiment 3 what was
fixed uh in version two uh and so on and
that is where data Version Control comes
in and this is the only lengthy text I'm
going to read today but data Version
Control is the process of systematically
tracking different versions of data sets
uh to ensure traceability auditability
and reproducibility and it's also uh to
enable members on one hand side to
experiment in isolation but also to
enable uh to work jointly on projects um
so I've highlighted the important things
here here first is systematic tracking
so we have some kind of systematic way
of dealing with our data um what we want
to achieve with a systematic way is
traceability auditability and
reproducibility um this is I'm going to
go this in more detail uh in a minute
but traceability we want to see what are
the changes that happen to the data set
auditability we want to understand why
have these changes been made do we still
confirm or are behind that reason why we
did this changes a you might want to
roll them back in which case we have
reproducibility so we want to get to a
previous state or to a different state
of the data set and then the
experimentation and isolation and
collaboration so when I do changes to
the data because I want to try something
out I'm doing an experiment um I don't
want this to break or affect the code
that my colleagues wrote um but on the
other hand if I have a great idea and I
did some changes to the data uh created
a new feature um I also want to share
that in an easy way with my colleagues
so that they don't have to redo the work
of doing that um and there are several
tools you can use to go about data
Version Control uh you see some of them
on the right um so DVC do lfs uh G lfs
or Delta Lake and yeah lake ofs is the
one that we going to present today
because it's the one that we like most
but in case you want to do your own
research or think you have different uh
differing requirements there are couple
of logos uh for your own convenience to
look up after um what do we do with
these uh with this D data version tool
so I've hinted at this in the definition
before but uh traceability so the
actions the changes that we do to the
data is something that we want to have
recorded uh and we want to reference
these different versions or want to be
able to reference these different
different versions either with a
timestamp or an identifier but just
somehow to some have some way to point
at the specific version uh and that ties
in with the next point reproducibility
so being able to retrieve that previous
version of the data set and being able
to add additional metadata so commit
messages something that explains why did
you do the changes uh that you did or
some other parameters that you do want
to lock and then the last thing the
collaboration um if you're familiar with
Git it's just being able to Branch off
um the state of the repository to work
with it and being able to merge it back
if you want everybody to be
uh yeah able to access your changes and
that's enough with a theory of uh
talking about data Version Control and
what it is and now we jump in talking
about Lake FS so Lake FS is an
open-source project um enabling you to
do data Version Control um and roll back
with a data leg um it's conceptually
really I mean obviously software Wise
It's Working a bit different because
data is different uh uh to code uh to
code at least also the amount that we
have and so on but it brings really
familiar interface to data so you have
uh a g-like interface with an where you
have your object storage is underneath
so your B data sits either on on Prem
servers or you can have it in the cloud
and you have then the representation uh
where you can tag revert uh commits you
can revert those commits uh and you can
merge and Fork uh branches uh the commit
snapchot are pointed or like capture the
repository at the specific point in time
and different to other tools like Delta
L uh Lake FS really creates uh it does
it in a smart way so it does not just
plainly copy the repository but it has
access to the state of the repository at
the time of every commit and does not
need to run through all the diffs to
create the the state of the repository
um so this is what a commit snapshot is
I've talked about the cloud support so
all the common clouds are involved so
AWS as or gcp or your own uh backends
and there are thirdparty Integrations so
uh spark or data lake or Iceberg if
that's something you interested in um
and then briefly showing you off how l v
looks like um so you see that it's
really like the the uh UI really looks
similar to what you are familiar with
probably from using GitHub so you have a
central repository where you can have uh
either directly files um in there or you
can have uh folders uh and the read me
that is down here so this is also the
I've changed the name to Pata H Brun but
if you use their lfs and just click
create the K Kickstart the quick start
example this is exactly what you see and
you can then also see in the menu um
that we can look for uncommitted changes
we can see the commit history there's
not much in there yet because the
repository was created and we have the
sample data uh we don't have any
uncommitted changes and we don't have
any additional branches uh besides the
default main branch but this really
gives you an intuition on what the how
Lake ofest looks uh looks like and how
you would interact uh with it and
there's really conceptually nothing new
here if you're familiar with kit uh this
feel will feel really uh like home for
you how to do uh versioning with lfs so
now that we familiar with uh with with
Git so we also recommend working with
branches so that you if you have want to
if you are interested in a specific
state of the repository you Branch off
that and if you have for example a
continuous uh on your main branch or
you're collecting data continuously and
you're working with that uh with the
data and you would always reference to
the main branch that gives up updates uh
you the view that the data that you
would experiment with uh would also be
updated and you have an uncontrolled
variable if you for example think about
accuracies or so on so if you then
branch of the new data is only added to
the main branch your Old Branch stays uh
stays the same consistent and you can uh
eliminate this uh confounding or this uh
variable this other uncontrolled factor
in your exper experiment you commit your
versions um whenever you made a change
that you think that is atomic that you
think you might want to roll back at a
later point or just reference to you can
create a commit and you can use these
and we will do that in practice in a
moment uh use these commits to reference
to uh to do reproducibility and with
that we now go to the Practical part of
using Lake of as spec which is a library
that we had applied AI developed and
open sourced um to interface with lfs
from your python
projects and that is basically the aim
of lfs spec is now to make the lfs
version data available with a file
system interface and you can basically
work with
uh with it like you would uh normally do
so we have here in the lake FS main
repository if we look at the Lakes file
that I've uh briefly covered on uh we
see that it's just a collection a big
collection of lakes and if we go now in
the Jupiter notebook that I have um and
look in there we can see that we indeed
got the same same file here um as you
also notice we haven't imported Lake FS
spec yet but we have installed it uh in
the system and that is to just read and
uh to just read from the files uh that
is enough because we have added the lake
FS file system to the under underlying
uh yeah file system so when when you use
this string uh and pass it to any
library that uses FS spec as a file
system under the hood and these are
pandas probably the most common one but
also uh duct Tob and others so
everything that is based on fspc if you
install L fspc uh will when you start
your uh your file path with this
identifier know how to parse whatever is
coming afterwards and whatever is coming
afterwards in this case it's just me uh
specifying first the repository that I'm
working in so if we look in Lake FS uh
in this so this is the repository I'm
working in um and then I specify the uh
the branch that we're working on and I
specify the file and without any
anything so you get just reading from it
just by having a l ofs spe in installed
gives you the ability to read from your
version uh data uh data
repository um we can write files uh the
same way so let's say we want for
whatever reason um just the German legs
out of that file so we briefly create
that and now want to write that um to
the file system now we need to import
something uh and we get the lfs file
system object from uh from P from the
lake of a spec package and then we use
what we call or we use the context
manager the transaction context manager
to uh really conduct our versioning
operations um what did we do here uh so
we have this transaction uh context
where we again specify the repository
that we want to operate on and we
specify the branch uh that we want to
operate on and get that in this handy
transaction object and then we can just
write to the uh with the same logic that
we just talked about write to the
repository of the branch uh and give it
a file name and then we can also do a
commit and get a commit message um we
could even write without using a
transaction but in this case we want to
do a a transaction because we also want
to do the commit of the so we don't want
to have uncommitted changes dangling
around um and now if we go here and look
on the commits we do see that the
German Lakes file uh was indeed indeed
added
here um what we also see uh what is very
uh very important here is this different
other new commit message and this is uh
because our transaction that we have
here creates an ephemeral Branch so a
branch that does not act or that is
deleted deleted afterwards but we do
this in order to safegard the operations
that we do so if somewhere in here uh an
error would occur you don't really want
to have an unfinished State on your main
repository and polluting or on what on
whatever Branch others might also depend
on so the transaction creates a new
Branch conducts all the uh specified or
all the everything that you coded up
here conducts that on the branch and
only then if the uh if the context uh
manager exits without an error the
branch is merged back so this helps you
to if anything goes south within the
transaction to not have that polluting
the state on your uh on your branch that
you're working on especially important
uh if you were to use this uh this logic
or L of aspect in kind of automated jobs
uh where you definitely don't want to
have some weird States in
between um we can for now we have worked
with uh data frames uh but we can also
access arbitrary files um so in my
repository locally I just have an
experimental Json file with some dummy
data in and again we start and conduct
uh with nothing really new so we start
with the transaction where we again
specify the repository and the branch
then we open the loc um we open the
remote file um called experiment. Json
we read in here in this line the local
file we can dump onto the uh onto the
remote file on our data repository and
add a commit in the end and when we now
look into what happens so I'm refreshing
here and we again see that our
experiment. Json file has been added and
we also see see the commit uh from the
safeguarding branch that was
created um we can also do more complex
versioning operations so for now we only
did writing and committing um but let's
say we are doing a more complex uh
experiment which involves us doing a
train test split and then we want to
have a specified Branch uh that we can
work on for a longer time so uh for that
we can again work with the Trans uh with
our transaction context manager and in
this case we again we specify the pi
data repository we give in the uh the
the base Branch but we can also specify
the branch name that is the so that it's
not an automatedly created ID that we
have seen here so these numbers were
autogenerated but we can just fix the
name and want the branch to be called
demo experiment and then we use the
second argument which is on one side
delete never so in this case the branch
is persisted and is not deleted uh when
we exit the uh transaction context
manager and we also set auto merge to
false because as of now we we didn't
have we we always deleted these
transient branches uh and merged them
before we deleted them merg them back
into the main branch um so we don't want
to merge in this case and we don't want
to delete um but then as we did before
writing the file and committing uh what
we have and then indeed if we look here
we do have the demo experiment Branch uh
on there um which also now contains our
train and test uh files which are not on
our main
branch so with this with this we've
created a more complex versioning
operations and uh other things that we
can do is is uh for example using uh
using tag so if you we've looked in here
and if we look at the commits we see the
commit sh so unique identifiers here but
if you want to have a specific state of
your repository that you want to refer
to more often it's really inconvenient
to just remember a long a random string
of numbers uh that's where tags come in
um so here we just put the Pata demo tag
uh onto
onto the commit um that we've
gotten down here so when we in this case
we we we did do the commit and we took
the commit or wrote the output of the
commit into a variable and we can we now
here have the commit and can access its
ID object uh ID property and we now make
create the reference of a tag and just
give it the name Pi data demo and now
whenever I use Pi data
demo uh it actually points to that very
commit so I don't need to remember or
use that uh long string of names but I
can just specify the repository Pi data
demo as the state of the uh the state of
the data that is that it's in and then
use the files uh the file name and then
I get the uh the test. CSV file at that
point in
time um but if we want to do automated
versioning so we use something like MFL
to track our experiments and we want to
have reproducibility and know exactly
what is the state of the data which data
went into that uh we would work with the
uh with the commit ID uh that is in the
commit object so lock
that and we see now if we ex execute
this and just take the commit object we
see that it's um indeed also was getting
the leg. parket file from the same state
of the repository at that point in time
time um and with that I'm coming to the
end of my talk um what did we learn
today so we've talked about data Version
Control uh we've talked about lfs um and
lfs spec and that enables you to do easy
read and write operations just by using
the uis instead of your natural or usual
file path with lfs you can do git style
versioning for your data and lfs spec
provides you uh transaction as a
safeguarded way uh to programmatically
conduct these versioning operations and
there are also two uh niceties that I
haven't really talked about but we have
within Lake FS spec automated discovery
of authentication credentials so if you
have a config file around it just uses
that but you can also pass the uh
authorization when you instantiate the
file system and we also have enabled
caching so if you have larger files and
up and downloads want to up and download
them we check if they have changed to
the state that is on your local machine
and only send data over the network if
that is really necessary and if you have
any questions the time is now this is a
link to the GitHub repo and you it's
open sourced and on pip already so if
you install lfs and uh do pip install
lfs spec you're ready to go to do
whatever you want to do with it thank
you yeah thanks Max for the
talk questions who's first
who works with stage of
versioning zimon has a question I saw
your hand it moved yeah Zon I want to
move for the second part of the
question first of all thank you very
interesting talk um can I also use Lake
FS to version entire image folders for
example I'm thinking back of my um
computer vision
projects yes uh you can use uh Lake FS
so this is not only files in the
repository but you can also have
subdirectories just so there's any kind
of file in there so for textual data
they have some kind of nice preview
functions that are not available for
other data types but in principle this
is just as long as you can store it as
data you can version it with
lfs and then maybe a follow-up question
um is there an upper limit in terms of
the amount of data that lfs can
efficiently handle do I run into some
issu isues if I just dump a terabyte or
something I think for a terabyte you
should not run into issues um Yan might
know a little more about the upper
bounds of Le so let's go to
m here yeah um this is actually one of
the reasons why we sort of like Lake FS
better than the other list of tools I
think the most popular tool out there is
DVC but you notice that if you do
like i' say thousands hundred thousands
of files d youc will get painfully slow
um it's known it's just not made for
that and that's not a problem the nice
thing is that um Lake aest comes out of
a company and they're really like big
data experts and they know what they're
doing and they have spent a lot of time
and effort on these kinds of cases so
terabytes is really not an issue um and
the nice thing is it's built every time
in a scalable uh way so you have the
optic storage in the back end that can
handle up to whatever provider you um
you have but also the way how you can
access files you can VI pre-signed URLs
you can shortcut you can scale it up but
having multiple gateways so there's all
sorts of things built in to yeah not let
you run into uh to those kind of
problems more questions
yeah I'm just interested how this works
internally let's say you have this one
terabyte file and then you change only
like a a bite or so and have a new
version like is is it completely um
copied or is does uh L FS Only Store the
diff between the original file and the
change uh so leg ofs does not only like
it does not work like Delta leg which
only stores the diffs so I think it
detects uh the files that have been
changed and uh copies those so if you
have one very large one terabyte file
and flip a bit I think that file would
be now stored twice um but it not just
copy for every version the whole data
repository but just uh has a smart
system underneath of pointing for every
commit to the versions of the file that
it wants to have and it then only copies
or have has a new version for a file
when that file also was
changed people won't hear you on the
stream sorry sorry you go to the lake FS
website there quite some background
information on how they designed it and
you can sort of see what makes sense to
do and where you have to be a little bit
more more
careful so Thomas has a question yeah
never having worked with uh data
versioning I would be curious to what
extent you know merge conflicts and
resolving those is practical on large
files I would expect that when you have
so personally I haven't really run into
problematic vers uh merge
conflicts I think if your data set has a
sufficient size doing that manually is
Not Practical so it would probably run
down into
a thinking about what were the changes
that were applied and which versions do
you want to give precedence
to um yeah that is my my gut reaction
how I would deal with that without ever
having faced the issue no it's a big
question Yan do you
agree I mean the thing is similar to
when you're writing code there's all
sorts of yeah different flow models on
how you collaborate on when you merge on
how you communicate and that problem in
that sense does not go away for data you
need to architect how you work um but it
really depends on the use case and um
and what you're doing initially when
you're experimenting a lot you could
also say it's like it doesn't make sense
to mer merge back into one main branch
you just have multiple experiments next
to each other if you have a production
system for instance that ingests data on
a regular basis then you say okay that
process goes into the main branch but
experiments are branching off and never
go back just make sure that you always
have a pipeline and the idea is that if
it be gets difficult to merge back into
a single branch that you actually start
making hierarchies of branches you can
you get quite far and quite Advanced
with it but you have to really really
plan it and architect it if it uh gets
bigger somebody last
question no then thanks again for the
talk Max thank
you
so now we can move to the break uh
there's some uh stuff you should know uh
if you see a fridge just grab a drink
yeah it's for yours to take um we're
moving up to the third floor now and
come back at halfast 8 also for people
in the Stream we're going to be back at
half past 8 and now we moving up and the
door will be closed so don't leave
anything behind you want to have access
to until halfast
so we're returning to the stream in a
minute after we solve some technical
problems
so
this
G
spe